est un monsieur thierry mariani merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
monsieur le premier ministre
chaque français doit avoir un accès égal
à l'éducation
et quand je dis chaque français je pense
que qu'on soit français de france ou
qu'en soient français de l'étranger et
ma question porte à l'heure actuelle sur
les moyens consacrés à l'éducation pour
les français de l'étranger
vous savez que les français de france
dépendent du budget du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
celui ci depuis 2013 est en nette
augmentation
madame la ministre les français de
l'étranger dépendent du budget du
ministère des affaires étrangères or
qu'est ce qu'on constate dans le même
temps où ce le budget de l'éducation
nationale pour les français de france
augmente celui consacré aux français de
l'étranger diminue on a aujourd'hui une
éducation nationale pour les français à
deux vitesses et je prendrai que deux
chiffres le réseau qui est animé par
l'aef lagence pour l'enseignement du
français à l'étranger
les crédits monsieur le ministre sont en
baisse de 7% depuis 2013
les bourses sont en baisse de 8% depuis
2013 alors que quand je dis alors que
dans le même temps le nombre des élèves
a augmenté de 9%
et qu'est ce qu'on vient d'apprendre
cette semaine alors que dans le débat on
nous a expliqué que n'aurait pas de
répercussions deux exemples monsieur le
premier ministre
le lycée de moscou où on vient
d'apprendre que la ffe ponctionner un
million d'euros pour équilibrer ses
comptes sur les caisses de réserve de
ceux de ce lycée même démarche à hô chi
minh
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les frais de scolarité risque
d'augmenter ça veut dire que les moyens
éducatifs risquent d'être limités ça
veut dire que les postes risquent d'être
supprimés alors ma question est simple
l'éducation nationale c'est un devoir
mais je voudrais madame la ministre
madame le premier ministre que ce devoir
soit le même pour les français de
l'étranger les français de métropole et
que et que les français de l'étranger
soit désormais des français à part
entière et non pas des français
entièrement à part mes filles parce que
mais merci monsieur mariani la parole
est à monsieur le secrétaire d'état a
changé les affaires européennes mais
ferme m désir merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député thierry
mariani
vous le savez le nouveau système de
bourses d de l'enseignement français à
l'étranger est conçu pour assurer non
seulement une plus grande équité entre
les familles mais aussi une meilleure
maîtrise de l'augmentation cette dépense
afin de prévoir une hausse régulière et
soutenable de la dépense effective la
prévision de dépense en 2016 et 209
millions d'euros
elle sera donc en fait en hausse de 7
millions par rapport à la dépense qui
devraient être constatés en 2015 avec
une budgétisation de 115,5 millions
d'euros nous avons donc la marge de
manoeuvre suffisante pour couvrir
l'intégralité de nos besoins et ne nous
semble donc pas nécessaire de modifier
le projet de loi de finances 2016 sur ce
point monsieur le député aucun jeune
français ne restera en dehors du système
faute d'argent le nouveau système de
bourse contrairement à celui de la prise
en charge est financièrement responsable
et il ne crée pas d'effet d'aubaine de
la part des établissements sur les
droits de scolarité
contrairement aux systèmes précédents
parce que vous aviez invité inventé une
sorte de principe des vases communicants
sans fond la réforme conduit à diminuer
le nombre de boursiers à 100% mais au
profit de ceux situés dans les tranches
de code petites et intermédiaires et il
n'existe pas d'éléments permettant
d'affirmer que le nouveau dispositif
découragerait les familles a sollicité
une bourse ce qui les conduirait à
quitter le réseau des écoles françaises
le nombre d'enfants bourcy non
scolarisés à la rentrée suivante sera
stable sur les dix dernières années au
cours autour de 8 % de boursiers
la baisse constatée du nombre de
demandes de bourses concerts
principalement la zone europe
au niveau des classes maternelles il
convient de prendre en compte
l'évolution de la sociologie des
français à l'étranger
de plus en plus de familles binational
s'inscrivent dans une perspective
d'expatriation durable et recherche une
intégration éducative pour leurs enfants
dans le système d'enseignement locale
l'éducation est notre priorité pour les
français en france comme à l'étranger je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre pour le
groupe radical république